it almost goes without saying that the
inner workings of the scp foundation are
kept secret from the general population
your average joe doesn't need or want to
know about the terrifying entities and
bizarre experiments happening behind the
closed doors of the various foundation
or overwatch council that oversees
everything that goes on within the scp
foundation they are considered the
highest authority within the
organization but very little is known
about them in fact according to one
official report in the scp foundation
archives the o5 council does not exist
at all stick with me here there are
decades of reports concerning the
council there is a wealth of historical
evidence pointing to their existence and
influence but they do not definitively
exist at least they don't right now take
a deep breath try and untangle the knots
we just tied in your brain sit back and
listen this is the story of
scp-001 the o5 council itself in 1965
scp foundation administrator william
cohen was preparing to leave his
position to prepare his successor h.v
oleander administer cohen drafted a
series of letters intended to pass on
important and highly guarded knowledge
to the man who would take his place in
the letter administrator cohen explained
that he was retiring early for a
specific reason writing
a dark linge to my mind sticking to
every neuron and slowing my every
thought in truth i'm unwell cohen's
decline had begun eight years prior in
late 1957 after the launch of soviet
space probe sputnik 1 into the earth's
orbit the foundation's interest had been
drawn to the probe after a foreign
signal had been detected trying to
communicate with it not a signal from a
foreign nation mind you but something
from much further away and likely
something that was not human whatever it
was it was trying to communicate and it
was getting closer on january 4th 1958
the signal stopped and an unidentified
object arrived on earth cohn was
summoned to the war room at site 0-0
much to his surprise it was highly
unusual for guests to be invited to the
site there they worked together to
identify the nature of the situation
with sputnik until a single burst of
gamma radiation was detected and
sputnik's orbit began to decay the
council panicked calling heads of state
and calling for as many resources as
possible they had worked themselves into
a frenzy and were planning to shoot down
the first space probe in earth's history
eventually the decision was placed in
cohen's hands let the probe land on its
own or shoot it down overwhelmed by the
council's intensity cohen told them to
do what they thought was best they shot
it down he did not want to but he
crumbled under the pressure there were
so many of them and only one of him and
they seemed so certain in their decision
this was the first decision in his
career that cohen regretted and it was
presumably followed by many more he
continued in his letter saying and now
what credibility do i have left to
disagree with them i'm but a mouthpiece
a sad old puppet tangled up and caught
in the very strings used to make him
dance cohen wrote his letter to a
successor with one warning just as i
have shown you vulnerability here in the
hopes i might gain your trust please
consider asking the same from those who
would insist you trust them in march of
1958 following the incident with sputnik
the o5 council collectively submitted a
notice to the foundation's leadership
committee they stated simply the
individual you call your administrator
has proven insufficient we solicit you
to make your preparations and nominate
another no individual members of the
council wrote in but rather submitted
their thoughts as a collective as if
thinking together as one single mind the
language used was also curious saying
your administrator rather than our
administrator the o5 council seemed to
think of itself as something separate
from the scp foundation its own entity
rather than simply a powerful arm or
leader of the organization itself on
june 11 1962 another notice was sent out
it read foundation a life lived in
service of the greater good is
invalidated if death does not also serve
on november 11
1965 a third notice was sent out this
time to all foundation staff please join
us in remembering the life and career of
administrator william cohen the only
constant is change because of this the
erosion of his skills abilities
knowledge and confidence was inevitable
administrator h.v oleander took over the
position for many years after cohen's
demise in 1988 he prepared to step down
and drafted a letter to his successor
natalia ellingbrook like cohen before
him oleander tried his best to explain
where he went wrong in the hope that she
might do better oleander began the
letter i used to have such an ego this
job this life and the burdens that
surround it crush and squeeze you until
all you have left is what they force you
to keep my mind and my soul feel as
though they've been contorted into the
shape of someone i no longer recognize
my predecessor may he rest in peace
described his years as if he were
trapped behind smokey glass and made to
watch a foggy well pass him by like some
sort of voyeur i too feel imprisoned but
i realized that it was never a looking
glass it is a mirror the events detailed
in the letter began in november of 1985
after a powerful storm had ripped
through new england and caused severe
damage to site-31's power grid during
the power outage a multi-stage
containment breach occurred and an
unnamed infovore escaped from the
facility the entity was lost until march
of 1986
when it was detected in a government
facility in warsaw poland determined to
make up for his previous failure
oleander organized a mission to bring
the entity back into custody his team
tracked it down and was prepared to
apprehend the entity's host when the o5
council expressed concern that this
behavior might cause an international
incident and intervened the council made
the decision to reach out to local and
international governments in poland
allowing the entity to escape to prypia
to ukraine oleander and the council went
head-to-head on this pushing and pulling
and becoming increasingly aggressive on
either side oleander could not make up
his mind about what to do listen to the
council or trust his own gut on april 26
1986 his indecision resulted in a
nuclear disaster in soviet territory not
only that but the entity still evaded
containment the mission was a complete
failure the o5 council submitted a
report on the incident stating we
recommended that the healing process
commenced by first assigning blame the
collective good would be served by
purging liability and we would have
helped anyone would have helped why deny
it by now the pattern has probably
become clear to you the administrator
and the council fall into conflict over
a difficult decision something goes
horribly wrong a new administrator is
chosen the former administrator writes
them a letter to prepare them for the
heavy demands of the job and the cycle
begins again
as you might expect during those days of
her administration oleander's
replacement natalie ellingbrook set down
to write a letter of warning to one
michelle wilkies who was chosen to
replace her ellingbrook began her letter
as you've likely surmised from our few
meetings i walk with a pronounced limp
and favor my left leg how i came to be
like this isn't especially interesting
but what it did to me might be of
interest to a person in your position
any man or woman changes when they are
exposed to pain simply put it has to go
somewhere if you hold it all within
yourself it may stay contained but it
will surely destroy you when you've had
your fill it festers in all the spaces
you let it occupy warping and scarring
what used to be healthy happy tissue sat
beneath some people have hobbies but me
i've always just had my work i've been
ringside for so much pain in my time
with the foundation my predecessor left
me a note much like i am leaving you and
in it he warned me of the tremendous
duty and guilt he hid in order to do his
job although the slings and arrows of
outrageous fortune stung him quite
keenly i assure you i have suffered
every bit his equal the breach at the
olympics in 94 losing control of site
248 in 96 botched facility transfer of
hong kong in 97 bombings in bali and o2
the dispute with the oria and the congo
and o3 the goc ultimatum in o4 she
continued although i have weathered much
my tenure is up not with the sort of
precipitating bang that ousted oleander
but rather the quiet whimper of stepping
away from a battle i no longer wish to
fight i am tired of the council calling
a meeting on every decision i try to
make and i'm tired of calling one on
every decision they try to make without
me i guess that reasoning is another
tribute to the selfish life i have led
my ideal way to say goodbye would have
been to simply stop coming in my desk
would have sat empty emails unread until
one day a career showed up with my keys
and badge but even here at the end of my
career the o5 council insists on
refusing to let me be by myself so
tomorrow i will play the part of a
dutiful officer resigning her post and
walk away from site zero zero with my
head held high and those overbearing
bastards in the rear view mirror i pray
that your head will never be so bowed as
mine has administrator wilkies took her
predecessor's words to heart and began
her tenure with a new proposal for
project tethys the project would include
modifications to the three gorgeous dam
facility at the yangtze river as part of
a containment procedure for entity
2005-c
et-011 the council refused to approve
her proposal administrator wilkies
insisted that they provide a list of
concerns explaining what their issues
with their proposal were the two argued
back and forth over the necessity of a
meeting until the council submitted this
snow tour we know how important it is to
get off on the right foot although this
body respects you and the autonomy which
you command we have also seen many come
and go you were chosen from your peers
but they have chosen many others in the
past we remain unconvinced before you
elling brook who spent her whole life
pushing others aside so she could lead
she left all others behind trees with no
roots do not hold to the ground before
her oleander who wanted so much to be
seen as your hero in white he could no
longer live with himself once his
clothes were stained but the sin does
not define the saint before him cohen
who wanted nothing more than to be the
one who made the decisions he collapsed
in on himself when there was no easy
victory no man is an island and a dozen
more whose names we have subrogated you
need us
you are not enough administrator wilkies
was offended by this response and argued
that the meeting was unnecessary she
asked for the council to trust her
expertise and the expertise of her
employees they responded your
distinctiveness did not arise from the
ether you are a synthesis of available
materials and experiences if needed
another could be synthesized we are
needed we are necessary we synthesize
you are not you cannot become we or
become they the choice is yours
administrator wilkie suddenly understood
the council was not a part of the
foundation they were something else
entirely though she couldn't be
completely sure what they were she knew
one thing for certain they were not her
friends she fired back at the council's
threats you cast your shadow over the
future with your threats and
intimidation certain we would be nothing
without you but i'm forced to wonder who
or what would you be without us i stand
with the countless thousands that have
died for our mission the people that
have engineered our solutions the people
that will build them and the people that
will risk their lives in order to carry
out these procedures in the hope our
mission might one day be complete
without them i know i would be nothing
we are willing to take our chances
without you i'm going to offer you the
same choice you gave me become we or
become they several days passed with no
response and administrator wilkie's made
the most difficult decision of her
career she suspended the appointment of
the 05 council until a day comes when it
becomes necessary again
secure area 0 0 has been set up around
the area containing scp-001
the area has been classified designated
level 6 or cosmic secret the coordinates
of this secure area are stored in
cranial implants placed in 15 carefully
selected foundation leaders including
ethics committee members and site
directors these candidates can
participate in voting once a vote is
called but are to be kept unaware of
their status as voters until it becomes
necessary if a super majority votes to
decrypt the contents of these cranial
implants the location of secure 0 0 will
be revealed to them if the security of
these implants becomes compromised
kogita.aic will generate a new protocol
and a new list of candidates will be
selected the original candidates will
have the encrypted information deleted
from their minds no one may access
secure area00 at any time for any reason
unless the aforementioned vote takes
place operation protocols defenses
building schematics and all other
information about the site have been
expunged from foundation records oh
what's this a new addendum has been
unlocked this is for your eyes and ears
only yes i'm talking to you do not share
this information with anyone else a
retinal scan has confirmed your identity
and the cogito protocol has been
executed you are receiving this addendum
because administrator michelle wilkies
is dead after nearly 20 years of service
before her death she prepared a
statement regarding the role of
administrator at the foundation the
addendum contains a message from
administrator michelle wilkes to you her
designated successor surprise you have
been chosen as the next administrator
for the scp foundation you may be
surprised asking really me yes
you you may not know it but you were
chosen quite some time ago the cranial
implant has been in place for years now
it is ready to be activated michelle
wilkie's message is intended to prepare
you for the trials and tribulations that
lie ahead and to encourage you to ask
yourself what kind of leader will you be
are you willing to do whatever it takes
to perform this most solemn duty the
following comes from the former
administrator herself listen carefully
and consider what she has to say your
future at the foundation the fate of
your subordinates and your very legacy
may depend on it consider now before
fate takes away the luxury of time what
type of person co-worker and leader you
want to be each and every day one of the
administrators before me was challenged
in terms both great and small during
their tenures and i was no exception to
this pattern the office you occupy is
not about the power and influence you
now command nor is it ever about the
unfathomable responsibility you must now
shepherd it is instead about the
character integrity and vision with
which you will meet the test of
leadership and should you prove worthy
surmount it you and the people you will
lead must be asked to undertake tasks no
person should ever be asked to carry out
yet duty and the safety of all mankind
demand that you make this sacrifice for
them for each other if your resolve
should ever falter know that everyone
you lead stands with you we are ready to
follow you into the blackest night if
you let us believe in the promise of
dawn but should your resolve ever break
the council awaits they will invite you
to cite 0-0 if you ask you need only
surrender best wishes m wilkies former
administrator what exactly is the o5
council that is a question not easily
answered they are not flesh and blood
not individual minds and feelings but
something else entirely they are a
collective something that thinks
breathes and votes together as one being
they view the world as two things
we
and they as you prepare to take on the
role of administrator keep in mind who
you are be strong be brave be resolute
and hold on to your sense of right and
wrong but if you ever should falter if
you decide to stop being you and become
we there is always site zero zero
remember even though they do not
officially exist the council awaits now
go check out
scp-001 the gate guardian and scp-001
the black moon for more enigmatic
scp-001 proposals